(dramatic music)
(squeak)
- Zim!
(thunder crashing)
- Yes, it is I!
Oh, wait, sorry.
You'll have to move along hideous goblin,
I'm posing dramatically
for when the Dib shows up.
- I am Dib.
- What?
Oh, ah, uh.
I've been expecting you, Dib.
(evil laughing)
- [Dib] Invader Zim, evil alien soldier,
disguised as one of us,
sent to infiltrate Earth
with his mechanical servants.
(alien yelling)
My name is Dib Membrane,
and I'm all that stands
between Zim and the
annihilation of our world.
(dramatic orchestra music)
(cat screeching)
- Oh man, Dib, not the coat.
- It makes me look mysterious.
Step aside, I've got a Zim to stop!
(dramatic orchestra music)
(gun firing)
(electrical zapping)
- You gotta order a million pizzas,
and then I gotta roll
around in them pizzas,
and that's the story about
how I turn into a giant pizza.
(squeaking)